What would a city look like without a government?
Imagine not lawless anarchy — there’s
still a government — federal, state, what-have-you
— just not its own government.
There would be no planning, no zoning, no
mayor, and no public infrastructure.
You might think it’s a silly question.
Who in their right mind would live there,
after all?
But imagine, for some reason, this city is
the size of Phoenix or Philadelphia — home
to about 1.5 million people.
Without government, who would make the trains
run on time?
Or even make sure there was a train in the
first place?
Who would inspect buildings for safety, or
test the purity of water?
You don’t, actually, need to imagine.
There is such a place.
It’s called Gurgaon — India’s privately-owned
city.
Because there were no public roads, water
pipes, energy lines, or fire stations, corporations
simply built their own.
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula.
Get both for just $15 a year.
Why would anyone — much less a million and
a half people — move to a place with no
central sewage or water system?
While Gurgaon may not be home to any natural
resources to speak of, it does have one big
thing going for it: proximity.
It’s about a half-hour drive southwest of
Delhi, India’s capital and the second-largest
city on Earth.
Instead of slowly sprawling outward into suburbs,
construction in Delhi was all of the sudden
forced to relocate.
In 1957, the Delhi Development Act banned
private real estate developers, leaving them
no choice but to move elsewhere.
The reason that elsewhere became Gurgaon was
a man named Sanjay Gandhi.
Sanjay dreamt of an Indian-made automobile
— an aspirational pride of the nation.
The government, at the time, argued its focus
should be on mass transit, not wasteful personal
cars — but Sanjay was the son of India’s
prime minister, and his wish, therefore, became
command.
Gurgaon was chosen for the factory precisely
because the land was worthless — rural,
undeveloped, and rather unimportant.
His car turned out to be a total failure but
was eventually bought by Suzuki, who, by the
early 80s, employed 20,000 workers in the
then small town.
Land laws are complicated in India — owners
must apply for permits, which can’t be transferred
to new owners and the whole process involves
many levels of bureaucracy.
Not to mention rampant corruption.
Because of this, Gurgaon may have remained
a small, industrial outpost forever, except
for a lucky coincidence:
Nearly all of its land was under the jurisdiction
of just one single office.
Of course, this one was no more immune to
corruption than any other office — but there
was a critical difference:
Say, for example, a company wants to develop
a plot of land.
To do so, it needs a permit.
The agency responsible can therefore demand
a bribe.
If it believes the land will generate $1,000,000
in profit, in theory, it can ask for as much
as $999,000, and the developer will agree,
still making a profit.
But, if the permit requires the approval of
two agencies, each will try to extract the
maximum value possible, for a combined $2,000,000
— twice the actual value — leaving the
company with no incentive.
Thus, unless all parties coordinate perfectly,
the land will sit empty and its economic potential
will be wasted.
Gurgaon, in other words, was no economic utopia
— bribes were common, but the lack of red
tape made paying them quick and easy.
That made all the difference.
Soon companies like Nestle, Coca-Cola, Dell,
and American Express flocked to the city’s
cheap labor, proximity to Delhi and an international
airport, and lack of bureaucracy.
And with them came a wave of skilled middle-class
knowledge workers and expats.
Delhi was old, crowded, dirty.
But in Gurgaon, developers introduced luxury
estates — walled-off high-rises with a shared
pool, clubhouse, and shopping mall.
There was just one tiny problem: There was
still no real government.
That meant no public transit, roads, sewage,
electric grid, water — you-name-it.
Still, to this day, many roads simply don’t
have names — including one outside its Civil
Hospital, which surely makes getting there
a bit tricky in an emergency.
And so, to induce demand, developers simply
created supply.
Whatever customers demanded, they provided.
Its Rapid Metro is the world’s first 100%
privately-owned modern light metro system.
To pay the bills, each station is auctioned
off to the highest corporate bidder who becomes
its “sponsor”.
You might meet your friend at Vodafone Belvedere
Tower Station — paid for by the British
telecommunications company Vodafone.
It’s even painted Vodafone red.
Two-thirds of the city’s population aren’t
connected to the main sewage line.
While they may flush their toilets without
knowing it, their pipes end in a septic tank
at the edge of the property, waiting to be
dumped just outside the estate walls.
Electricity may be erratic — but those on
the 30th floor don’t know the difference
— their power is backed up by privately-owned
diesel-powered generators.
The public employ just 4,000 police officers,
while developers maintain a legion of 35,000
security.
The city’s fire preparation is equally comical.
In 2008, there were just 14 public fire engines,
despite the central government mandating no
fewer than 42 for a city of its size.
Worse, their pumps could only spray up to
40-meters.
The tallest building is three hundred.
Real estate companies had no choice but to
build their own fire stations, which act as
a quasi-public service in times of emergency,
helping anyone in need.
Its business hub, Cyber City, boasts having
“weapon-mounted” Scorpio SUVs, a security
force of 500, and 8,000 security cameras.
Now, on paper, all of this development was
part of a “public-private partnership”
— private companies would build their own
infrastructure, and the city would connect
it all.
But, of course, without any system of enforcement
or an explicit contract, developers built
only what their customers demanded and nothing
more.
Despite being the third-largest source of
tax revenue to the central Indian government,
somehow a formal municipal body was only created
in 2008, by which time it was already home
to over a million people.
Even then, its power is extremely limited.
About the only thing it did was rename the
city — though few noticed.
If Gurgaon is an accidental experiment in
what happens when corporations are left to
fill the role of government, what are the
results?
The answer depends on who you are.
Its privately-owned islands rival any of the
world’s great cities in cleanliness and
comfort.
Tiger Woods once played a round at the Arnold
Palmer designed DLF Golf and Country Club,
The Fortis Memorial Hospital draws people
from all around, and its high rises offer
every luxury under the sun.
But step outside these artificial islands,
even just an inch, and everything changes.
Untreated sewage is dumped straight into the
river, electricity is sporadic, the air is
polluted, extreme flooding is not uncommon,
and traffic jams are a daily fact of life.
In 2016, thousands of cars were stuck on the
road during a flood, which canceled school
for two whole days.
At one point, traffic got so bad that a judge
ordered the pause of toll collection to speed
things up.
So, what is Gurgaon?
A brutal, lived lesson on the limits of Capitalism?
Or an extraordinary example in the lengths
the free market will go to fill in the gaps,
all on its own?
In short: yes.
This, on the other hand, is a city that doesn’t
actually exist — but one with just as powerful
a lesson.
“The Unknown City” is a video which completely
blew me away — it’s a stunning 3D-rendered
journey by Neo, exclusively available on Nebula
— the streaming platform that, as I’m
sure you know by now, was built by and for
creators.
Roughly every other PolyMatter video also
has bonus or extended content on Nebula, like
this one about How Corporations Vote in Hong
Kong, or this one about the upcoming Beijing
Olympics.
Get access to great documentaries on CuriosityStream,
like this one, which journeys through the
world’s most dangerous road, in India — AND
Nebula by signing up with the link in the
description for just $15 bucks a year — not
a month but a year.